des dizaines de palestiniens qui
applaudissent et chante en guise de
célébration dimanche soir la circulation
sur cette promenade donnant accès à
l'esplanade des mosquées a de nouveau
été autorisés une levée des barrières
vécu comme un juste retour des choses
par ses fidèles palestiniens depuis le
début du ramadan israël a décidé
d'imposer nouvelle situation autour de
la porte de damas
cette nouvelle réalité ne correspond pas
aux besoins des habitants de la ville en
tant que musulmans nous avons l'habitude
de nous asseoir à côté de la porte de
damas après les prières et les forces
d'occupation ont décidé de fermer cet
espace
les palestiniens ont récupéré un de
leurs droits l'histoire ici à la porte
de damas n'est pas le retrait de ces
barrières mais la raison pour laquelle
les israéliens avaient mis ces barrières
en premier lieu maintenant les
palestiniens peuvent se déplacer
librement dans cette zone et se
retrouvait à un endroit où il est
peut-être en raison de l'épidémie de
covin 19 les forces de l'ordre
israéliennes avaient récemment fermé
l'accès est interdit tout rassemblement
sur cette promenade provoquant la colère
des palestiniens
habitués à se réunir près de la porte de
damas durant le ramadan jeudi soir les
tension était encore montée d'un cran
lorsque ces derniers ont voulu s'opposer
à une manifestation de juifs de droite
radicale à proximité s'en étaient
suivies des heurts particulièrement
violents avec la police israélienne
faisant plus d'une centaine de blessés
parmi les palestiniens
à dimanche quelques heures avant la
levée des restrictions et des centaines
de manifestants avaient décidé de se
rassembler à gaza pour apporter leur
soutien aux palestiniens
aujourd'hui nous sommes sortis avec
cette grande foule pour déclarer notre
soutien aux jeunes de la ville de
jérusalem qui font face à l'occupation
ou héros qui se posent aux israéliens
qui détruisent la ville de jérusalem ne
jérusalem ne faisons qu'un face à
l'occupant nous envoyons un message à
l'ennemi sioniste et au sanctifié la
jeunesse le peuple et la résistance de
gaza sont avec vous et ne vous lâcherons
pas nous serons toujours en première
ligne et nous donnerons nos âmes et
notre sang en sacrifice pour jérusalem
et la mosquée al-aqsa
bien que la police israélienne et
dimanche soir disperser la foule et
procéder à une arrestation après que des
drapeaux palestiniens ont été brandis à
la suite de la levée des restrictions
sur l'esplanade des mosquées
les tensions semblent être retombés un
retour au calme qui reste fragile